um thank you everybody for joining my
talk today so I'm vibha I work as a
machine learning engineer at drink so we
are basically a sustainable Finance
startup and uh we use technology to help
investors and businesses make more um
environmentally sustainable uh
Investments uh so a little bit about me
I started my NLP Journey around uh four
to five years back and uh back then
there were very few uh ml Frameworks so
I started with uh Tech summarization
systems and uh you know to make to make
something even uh very simple you had to
deal with like a lot of tensors and
write a lot of code and uh there was no
unified way of basically doing anything
uh but now we live in a very different
world we have a lot of great uh ml
Frameworks uh and uh the way we think
about and build our ml application uh
has changed significantly and uh one
such ml framework is Haystack uh which
I'm quite fond of I will uh explain why
soon
um so yeah so basically what we're going
to talk today is uh what is the Q a task
uh how does a typical uh q a system look
like how do you build uh such a q a
system uh uh using Haystack to answer uh
questions on a sustainability report uh
and then yeah we'll open it up for Q a
so uh what is the extractive Q a task
right so it's basically a flavor of uh
question answering uh and uh in in
today's talk we would consider uh
extractive question answering over a
close set of documents uh meaning to say
that uh uh the user asks uh questions
over a close set of documents and the
answer that you get is from within the
document itself so yeah this is uh one
FL this of course this is one of the
flavors of q a and there are other
flavors of a question answering task as
well uh such as uh you can probably ask
questions over the contents of a web
page and uh uh generative question
answering Etc uh but we would not be
discussing uh those topics today uh so
the but I think that you can uh knowing
these Concepts you can extrapolate these
Concepts to uh the other flavors of the
Q a task as well
so how does typical question answering
system look like right so a question
answering system basically has two
important moving Parts one is uh the
Retriever and the other is the reader so
what is the retriever right so the
retriever is basically it can be an
algorithm or it can be a model uh and uh
given a question what it essentially
does is that it uh and and of course a
set of passages what it essentially does
is that it ranks these passages based on
how relevant these passages are to that
uh particular question uh so the the
most relevant Passage would get the
highest score and would be ranked number
one and then uh the Nick and followed by
the uh subsequent lesser relevant
passages and then what we do is that you
choose the top km so this top K can be
like top five or top 10 uh depending on
your use case and then you take these uh
top K passages and pass it to the next
stage which is the reader stage
now what the reader essentially does is
that uh it basically uh so basically
given the same question and a passage
what the reader essentially does is that
it predicts the answer span so for
example here if there is a question so
what is the company's approach to
climate change and uh you see a
paragraph that has been uh sent by the
retriever to the reader and what the
reader does is that it predicts the span
so in our case probably it's from the
zeroth character to say the 250th
character right so it basically predicts
this span and it kind of shows where the
exact answer lies in that uh passage so
this is basically what a typical uh
reader retrieval system would look like
um and I think one thing that I think
anybody who's building a q a system
should probably remember is that uh the
retriever is more important than we
think uh because as we saw in the
previous uh diagram the output of the
retriever is the input to the reader so
um if the paragraph that actually has
the correct answer has not been picked
up by the retriever even if you have
like the best reader model in the world
uh you would still not be able to derive
uh you know like come to the correct
answer and hence uh when something is
going wrong in your q a system it's uh
really important that you see uh you
know how the reader is performing and I
think a very uh helpful indicator would
be uh what is the position that the
reader is giving to the correct answer
right so uh monitoring this would
actually uh help you fix your q a system
if uh something is going wrong
so uh yeah there are basically two types
of major types of retrievers uh one is
the term-based Retriever and the second
is the semantic retriever uh so the term
based retriever uh the retrieval
basically happens based on uh the term
matches between the query and the
passage so for example uh if you're
looking for environmental impact
assessment uh then uh the passages uh
which actually contain these tokens in
some way or form uh would be ranked
higher uh whereas uh in the case of
semantic retriever the retrieval happens
based on the semantic embeddings of the
query and the passage so uh even suppose
uh there is no term that matches between
the query and the passage even if there
is
um uh they semantically have you know a
similar meaning uh then the passages
would still be picked up by the
Retriever and uh some examples of the
term based retriever are tfidf and bm25
and some examples of the semantic
retriever are the DPR which is the dense
passage retrieval and the embedding
retrieval
so uh we kind of uh I mean we just went
through like what a typical q a system
looks like now how do we build such a
system right so um if you have to build
such a system from scratch like just
using a plain Python and uh an
elasticsearch client Etc it's quite a
lot of work and uh even to just do a
very simple POC it can probably takes a
few weeks or a few months to even just
see initial results and God forbid if
you make even a small mistake uh uh you
know there would be uh it's just hard to
debug and you know you can just get
erroneous results uh so it that doesn't
seem like a a good way to go about it so
so how do you what is a better way to
handle something like this right so
um Haystack right so Haystack uh is an
open source framework
uh that makes building uh NLP systems in
general more straightforward uh so
Haystack I the way I see it is like
Haystack is basically like a toolbox uh
that has all the tools that you need uh
to build NLP systems and uh yeah you
just have to choose the tools uh wisely
okay
um so let's try to build a simple q a
system using Haystack uh so here we have
a sustainability report of a company
which is around 62 pages
and we want to find a find uh you want
to find an answer to our question so our
question being uh what's the company's
approach to climate change right so this
is our question and um how do we go
about doing this right
um
okay so the first thing that you have to
do is basically uh create a document
store right so the document store is
where you store your documents and index
your documents right so you can use uh
different type so in our case we're
using the uh elasticsearch document
store but you the haystack also provides
uh I mean allows you to use uh other
document stores like pine cone uh
viviate faises
etc etc uh and then you basically have
your elasticsearch instance running on
your local system or on the elastic
cloud and you just need to uh pass the
the host name the port where it's
running and the username and and the
credentials and also uh the index that
you want uh to index on so you pass all
these uh uh you you pass all these
parameters and then when you run this
when you basically create an
elasticsearch document store what
essentially happens is that it creates
an index for you so in our case it's
just um April 17th test one
um yeah so basically uh as you can see
uh there is nothing that's indexed uh
currently it's just an empty index that
was created for you
the next thing that you have to do is
basically you need to index the document
to the document store right so now we
have a PDF document which contains uh I
mean yeah it's basically a PDF document
so you need to First extract the text
out of this uh PDF document so you can
do this using uh something like Pi
Tesseract or something if you want like
better accuracy and like better quality
of results you can use something like
Google doc AI uh uh and basically
perform an OCR on your PDF and extract
all the text out and once you've
extracted all the text from your
document what you essentially need to do
is that you need to break this text into
smaller chunks
so you can do it using some heuristic
like you know maybe based on the new
land character or maybe on a paragraph
level or a block level uh and basically
you have now you have all these chunks
right to the next thing that you have to
do is that you create this document
object and then uh you have you
basically take the text I mean you
basically need to uh send the content
right so the chunks that you had
prepared earlier so you basically uh
fill in the content and then you also
can have like these meta Fields uh which
are the fields on which you can perform
a filtration later so uh your meta
Fields can be something like the
document name or the date and the time
uh that the document was created
Etc and you so uh yeah so you can
basically create these meta fields and
uh so you would say so you would finally
end up with like a list of documents
right so and then what you do is that
you just have to do a very simple thing
you just have to uh call the write
documents function over your document
store and what this would essentially do
for you is it would write all the
documents onto your uh elastic index so
here as you can see uh we had around uh
the the basically the 62 page PDF was
converted into uh 953 chunks and uh this
one line basically inserted all of those
chunks uh into our document store
right so which is pretty nice
and then the next thing that you have to
do is uh create your retrievers right uh
so your retriever is basically a layer
on top of your document store so that
determines uh what is the retrieval
algorithm that needs to uh act on your
document store so it can be something
like a BM as simple as bm25 tfredf or uh
something sparse like that or it can
also be a a dense retriever so in our
case we have chosen the uh embedding
Retriever and then yeah you have to
specify the document store on which you
want the retrieval to happen uh and then
in our case we we are using the sentence
Transformer model to actually create
these embeddings and when you call the
document store dot update embeddings a
lot of things happen under the hood
uh so what uh essentially happens is
that for each of uh the documents that
you had previously indexed uh they would
be passed through the uh sentence
Transformer model and uh the embedding
is obtained and they are even stored
back into the uh in in into the index
into your index so in this case we have
like a a new field called embedding
which is like 760 I think in this case
it's around 768 Dimension so uh
basically uh the embeddings are stored
back to your index itself and this is
just done by like a one single
um one single line of code
um okay so the next uh thing that you
have to do which in my view is optional
is create a reader
um uh I mean it depends on your use case
as to what you want to do but you can
create a reader on top of this so in our
case uh we are choosing the Roberta
which is uh fine-tuned on uh the squad 2
data set which is a question answering
data set and uh yeah we create a farm
reader and we basically create a reader
and finally uh all you have to do is
that you have to basically create your
pipeline now so you have your uh extract
so in our case we want to create an
extractive QA Pipeline and uh just pass
it uh the reader and the retriever right
so your your
um your your extractive QA pipeline is
ready it was like just a few lines of
code and it's ready and then the next
thing that you do is um you basically
have to run your pipeline uh with your
query and you can also pass some
parameters like uh the top K retrieval
the top key values for the Retriever and
the top K values for the reader in our
case uh the retriever top case 100 that
means it says that a past 100 most
relevant passages or to the reader and
the top K value for the reader is 10 so
that means uh pass the top 10 most uh
top 10 answers in which you have like
most confidence back to the user and
actually you can also uh pass filters in
this stage like you can filter by uh a
certain date and say that you know I
want only documents that have that were
inserted in the system after Jan 15th or
whatever you know you can specify that
date and maybe you can also specify the
document from which you want these
answers to come from so you can also
have these filters
and uh yeah and then you get the answer
so in our case the question was uh what
is the company's approach to climate
change
and our answer is uh it's methodical so
saf Holland approaches the topic of uh
climate protection methodically uh The
Point of Departure was to draw up a life
cycle assessment uh Etc and uh yeah so
and it also gives you the document from
which uh uh this this content was pulled
so the source from where this content
was pulled
and uh this is honestly the tip of the
iceberg right so there is so much more
that you can do using Haystack you have
you can collect feedback uh using the
haystack annotation tool and then you
can uh use the train method of the
reader and Retriever and fine-tune the
reader and the Retriever and that's
that's quite straightforward and then
you can also and in the latest releases
of haystack uh there are actually like
you can all other like the concepts of
prompt templates and prompt models um
and agents and uh using this you can
also leverage uh the capabilities of GPT
3.5 and gpt4 and
um and also do multi-hop QA Etc
and another thing I feel that it's uh
definitely uh worth checking out is a
lang chain so Lang chain I would say is
very similar to Haystack in a lot of
ways it also acts as the glue uh to kind
of uh glue a lot of uh you know like
basically uh uh Like Glue a lot of
components and build a similar system
but I feel uh both of them have their
own pros and cons for example Haystack
is uh I mean is really good on building
question answering systems whereas Lang
chain uh is good at building chat Bots
uh but then more or less they kind of
have a same functionality uh so I think
it's like if if you I mean you can try
them both and you know see uh which one
suits you better
um
yeah and
um yeah so I have uh I've created a
small repo which has a an example of
everything that we just spoke about uh
I've just created a notebook uh which
has all the code uh about what we just
spoke and uh feel free to give it a try
and uh yeah let me know what you think
about it
foreign
thanks very much also perfect on the
time with a bunch of time for questions
there's two on slider of course I forgot
again to mention that we're using slido
to collect the questions also for the
remote viewers so please if you have any
questions head over there I think by day
three most of you are aware of how that
works what method do you use to create
the document chunks
uh currently we use uh doc Google doc AI
so that already has this concept of
blocks and we use that but of course
depending on uh your use case it you can
also use uh paragraphs or you can use
just new line characters
um yeah it really depends on your use
case and you can like you know uh do a
bunch of experiments and see uh what's
really giving you good results
and also depends on the type of
documents that you're working on if it's
like slack messages or something like
that I think that would be like a a
totally a different way of handling it
but uh of course if it's a PDF document
uh I think paragraph level would work
pretty well
thanks why did you decide to use
elasticsearch instead of pine cone when
you generated the chunks with elastic
which text are you looking for
uh I mean uh one thing is that you know
elasticsearch is open source uh that's
one reason and uh I mean I I mean I mean
we are kind of probably will have to
move to Pinecone because uh uh I mean
Pinecone has like a lot more
functionality but for now I think uh
elasticsearch is like uh pretty good and
it was good to do trials uh and yeah
it's free and open source
um
how to come up with good hyper
parameters for top K in Retriever and
reader
okay
um so I think
um I mean this is a very uh tricky
question right because it depends really
on uh your use case
um in my case what I did was uh I I did
a bunch of experiments uh to come up
with uh what is a good top K value uh
but ideally I feel like it uh you know
if you if you're if the correct answer
is not coming within the top 10 at Max
from the retriever I think you'd need to
go for fine you need to go with like
fine tuning the retriever because like
if your value like if the correct answer
is not coming in top 10 then you'll be
like ascending a lot of data to the
reader and reader is a very
computationally intensive step so you
need to make sure as much as possible
that uh you know you you you stay in the
top 10 at least so you I think yeah I
think yeah that's would be my answer
things is it possible to extract answers
that are distributed over different
passages
so do you currently uh uh that does not
cater to that but it is definitely
possible to do long-form q a uh using
Haystack there are separate modules for
that and it's definitely possible you
can have like your answer being spread
out on two three documents and you can
still uh do that
um
why would you say that link chain is
better suited for chatbot and haystak's
better for QA system
um okay so I mean the reason why I feel
that is that because you know initially
Haystack uh uh it was I mean it was
meant to kind of find the answer uh in a
haystack right because like everything
like currently uh they're moving towards
uh uh you know like giving support to uh
chatbot systems like doing multi-hop QA
and QA and everything but initially when
they started off uh it was that that was
not really their goal uh so I personally
feel I'm more comfortable uh using
Haystack for Q a because uh that's what
they're they were really good at but now
they are also trying to move into uh uh
doing things like multi-hop QA and
things like that but uh uh land chain I
feel like uh their their main aim was
not for question answering right it was
uh it was it is it's always been about
uh creating agents having a multi-hop QA
and and things like that so I think it's
just that they have grown in a certain
vertical and they have grown a certain
vertical so uh I feel that you know
they're good in their own spaces but I
think both of them are trying to like uh
do everything so I think uh yeah they're
growing in both like each of them are
growing into each other's spaces so I
think that's how it's going forward
is there a limit of data which can be
sent to the reader
uh I mean I have not faced yeah of
course there is a limit to the data to
which uh that you can send to the reader
reader uh but I have not faced that
problem because uh we uh send only
paragraph chunks so those are not really
long uh but uh yeah I think the uh there
is I mean depending on which model
you're using for the reader I think it
it will it may be like 512 tokens or
something like that but
um yeah that would be a limit depending
on which model you're using for the
reader
we compute the embedding of the PDF and
store them in a vector database
so you avoid to search in the text
yeah that's exactly uh what we uh we're
doing that you know we we would store
the embeddings of uh every uh passage uh
in the vector store and finally you're
searching only on uh the embedding space
you're not searching on the text uh
anymore
at least with uh density retrievals like
the embedding retriever
where is the computation happening to
retrieve the results
I mean uh you can actually I mean
currently it just happens on a single
system but you can actually separate out
the nodes on which uh these computations
are happening you can use uh Frameworks
like Ray and uh you can actually like uh
split out the compute intensive reader
part onto another node and
um have the retriever on the Node that's
possible but uh yeah I'm currently not
using it but it's definitely possible
any more questions from your room
so let's say the important piece of
information in a document is encoded in
an image
sir that
contains or processes this information
yeah I mean it depends on uh what kind
of image right so if it is a graph or if
it's something uh like a table I think
uh you'll have to have like uh some I
mean the current whatever I showed right
now would not really do that you'll have
to have uh abilities to basically
process that graph or that table and
extract information from that uh and uh
go ahead so I think there are some
models that do that like especially for
tables I think there are some models
that have the ability to extract
information from tables uh yeah but I
but you know I I mean that's something
that we are yet to explore but uh it's
it's some at least for tables it does
exist but for graphs and other kinds of
images I'm not very sure
thank you
someone else
if not one final question oh yeah sure
um so you said that your company is
focused on sustainable sustainable
Finance right
um but have you thought about maybe
productionizing
um whatever you manage to build for like
other
to sell it to like other companies for
other completely different contexts like
I don't know history or
whatever other use cases uh you mean
like using similar models for different
uh use cases yeah but like outside of
sustainability
um like theoretically these Concepts can
be used outside of sustainability as
well uh but currently we don't I mean
because of a business model and
everything we do not uh I mean that's
not
uh that's not on a roadmap uh
um but and this is this is a part of the
project there's also a platform uh where
you can actually manually do reporting
and everything and this is going to
augment uh that so yeah this is not yet
in production okay thanks
one final question from slido thank you
very much for the nice talk
are your slides going to be published
somewhere
so I think
I think they will be uploaded to the
schedule so if you check the schedule
later the on pre-talks that's where they
will be all right thanks very much again
please another one Applause
and enjoy your lunch